all right why is the Kentucky Derby
running behind me because it's happening
this weekend it's a tradition it dates
back to the 1800s I'm talking about the
big Derby hats you know the ones like
this big and the fascinators as well so
yeah the big race is on Saturday but we
got the accessories for you this morning
Candace Charles live at prowess designs
at Decatur Enoki with just how much
you've got to Pony up for something
really nice and fancy Candace good
morning to you
fashionista knows you gotta have the big
beautiful hat or fascinator for the
Kentucky Derby and I have prowess
designed to share e Gibbs here with me
thank you so much for joining me tell me
a little bit about what's trending this
season so what's trending is going to be
either your pastels or your lilacs like
what you're wearing or soft pinks or
you're going to go the opposite
direction and do hot pinks and oranges
or you could even do blues and greens
nice okay what makes process designs a
place to go to for your hats so it's
because we are very big on personalizing
your look so we have things here so we
can customize them with feathers we have
hatch rims and all those kinds of things
that we also size your hat to your head
nice and I know you got a little extra
piece for my fascinator here to make it
extra special and this is just one of
the things that this year does here at
prowess designs tell us really quickly
some of the price ranges so we start at
about 45 for the fascinators especially
for the children we go up to 150 for the
fascinator soda look and the hat for the
Derby nice okay now how much could
people be spending elsewhere oh gosh you
can go as high as your as your wallet
will allow so you can go with anything
from maybe 200 generally up into the
thousands it depends on your millinery
but go for it but to share I got you
here right I have got you here anytime
amazing thank you so much for joining us
this morning it's been wonderful now she
is open Friday Saturday and Sunday at 10
A.M right here at the Fantastic Indoor
Swap Meet but you can also go online and
get that order in now you guys you can
find out more details on our website
8newsnow.com for now live from
Providence at the Fantastic Indoor Swap
Meet I'm Candace Charles 8 News Now